I am losing two pounds per week, okay, well, that's not good.
Two pounds per week in your eating, everything you can,
that's not good, we should have a full conversation, so we don't want a person.
So a person can be in weight loss with cancer because they made drastic changes in their diet.
And they're overweight when they start, and making those drastic changes and making lifestyle changes,
you could go into a weight loss where you're losing a couple pounds a week because of those changes.
If you're still above your normal weight or what you would ideal, your ideal weight that I wouldn't be too concerned about that,
or if it's coming from those dietary changes, if you're already at your ideal weight and you're still losing weight, then that's a concern.
We need to address that.
So your schedule will tie within you if that fits into your category.